good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we begin with an
unexpected Fox newsletter just moments
ago Barry Weiss of sub stack began
posting part two of the Twitter files
now these are assessments of internal
documents from Twitter they've been
hidden under previous management but are
now being exposed by Elon Musk who just
bought the company
so first musk last week gave a trove of
documents to Matt Toby of substack and
out of Barry Weiss Weiss is unpacking
all of this right now live on Twitter in
a Twitter thread what she has revealed
so far confirms what many suspected but
none knew for certain which is that
Twitter routinely censored prominent
critics of the Biden Administration did
so in secret without telling anyone and
with no factual justification whatsoever
this is known as Shadow Banning Twitter
did it all the time now publicly they
denied doing it people who were being
Shadow banned suspected something was up
but they didn't know now officially
Twitter's Chief legal officer Chief
sensor at Twitter Vijaya got a woman who
was rewarded by the byte Administration
for her work on their behalf said that
quote we do not Shadow ban and we
certainly don't Shadow ban based on
political viewpoints or ideologies
that's what she said that was a lie and
the documents that Barry Weiss is
posting right now including screenshots
of Twitter's internal censorship tools
prove that it was a lie
one of Twitter's targets for shadow
Banning was a stop Stanford Professor a
physician PhD called Jay bhattachara one
of the most impressive people in
American Medicine someone we've had on
this show many many times there was no
justification for censoring Jay
bhattachara except he was one of the
authors of the Great Barrington
declaration which very early in the
so-called pandemic infuriated our
country's Public Health establishment
including Tony fauci
by opposing covid lockdowns Jay about
achara has spent his career studying the
health effects of various policies on
vulnerable populations so he knew that
coveted lockdowns would harm children
and he said so that has turned out to be
true but Twitter doubtless at the
request of the authorities Shadow band
professor batachara of Stanford for
saying this out loud they prevented his
tweets from trending and that meant that
most users could not see his tweets
though they were factual
Twitter also Shadow banned Fox's Dan
bongino according to Weiss Twitter at
one point slapped bongino with a search
ban that made it impossible for users of
Twitter to find tweets by Dan bongino
because they were inaccurate no because
they were accurate that was the crime
that's always the crime they never
punish you for lying they only punish
you for telling the truth
Twitter also flagged Charlie Kirk's
account with a do not amplify tag
Weiss reports that quote the group that
decided whether to limit the reach of
certain users was the Strategic response
team global escalation teamer SRT g-e-t
the team often handled up to 200
separate cases a day
another group within Twitter called site
Integrity policy policy escalation
support notice the bureaucratic handles
here it's like the military that group
also hadn't handled Shadow Banning and
that group included got a as well as
Twitter Executives Joel Roth and Prague
Agarwal who ran the company
none of this has been previously known
it was never disclosed to the public
wasted threat is ongoing it's being
updated as we speak and of course we'll
bring you more information as we get it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight